en 2020 on a recensé en france 27 1659
cas de violences à l'encontre de
policiers c'est deux fois plus que lors
de l'année 2001 chiffres malgré tout en
baisse par rapport à 2010 neuf années de
gilet jaune mais comment se manifeste
cette animosité dans les yvelines le
fait le plus récent aux clayes-sous-bois
deux jeunes de 17 et 20 ans ont été
arrêtés après avoir attaqué la police le
27 octobre dernier une attaque organisée
l'un lance un caillou sur le véhicule
pour briser la vitre l'autre tente de
tirer un mortiers d'artifice à
l'intérieur le verdict est tombé le 9
novembre dernier pour le plus âgé
d'entre 30 mois de prison dont six avec
sursis le cas du second est toujours
sous investigation du juge préférant
garder le silence il a été incarcéré en
maison d'arrêt en attendant le jugement
il a été également mise en cause pour
vol en réunion sous la menace d'une arme
et vol avec effraction mais la nuit la
plus représentative de ces agissements
et la nuit d'halloween 2021 où plus
d'une dizaine d'incidents ont été
enregistrés dans le département à
elancourt les mureaux trappe
aubergenville ou encore montigny le
bretonneux
cela se caractérise surtout par des tirs
de mortiers envers les patrouilles mais
aussi des poubelles enflammées et des
jets de pierres
contacté par notre rédaction la
gendarmerie des yvelines n'a pas
souhaité répondre préférant attendre la
fin des procédures en cours culture anti
flics tension entraînée par le kobe 19
ou encore escalade de la violence les
hypothèses sont nombreuses pour tenter
d'expliquer ces phénomènes pour rappel
une dizaine de policiers et gendarmes
sont tués en mission en france chaque
année ils étaient onze en 2020